l'assassinât de georges besse président
directeur général de la régie renault
revendiqué aujourd'hui par le groupe
terroriste action directe
le ministre des affaires sociales
philippe seguin présente son plan de
rationalisation du système d'assurance
maladie pour redresser les comptes de la
sécurité sociale football sélectionneur
de l'équipe de france henri michel
renforce le système défensif des
tricolores qui rencontrent demain la
république démocratique allemande ce
sera en direct à 20h sur antenne 2
aujourd'hui mardi 18 novembre 1986
nouvelle journée de détention pour les
otages français du liban marcel fontaine
marcel carton
jean paul kauffmann aurel cornéa et jean
louis normandin n'ont toujours pas été
libérés
et j'ajoute que l'annoncent par un
interlocuteur anonyme de la libération
de monsieur carton hier soir à beyrouth
ne s'est pas confirmé il pourrait s'agir
d'une très mauvaise plaisanterie
bonsoir georges besse est mort hier soir
en rentrant chez lui il a été assassiné
ce mot imprimé par tous depuis ce matin
comme une page sanglante et revendiquée
depuis cet après midi par le groupe
terroriste action directe c'est le
douzième attentat revendiqué depuis le
début de cette année les tracts sont
signés commando pierre overney le
militant gauchiste tué en février 72 par
un vigile de la régie renault
l'enquète de police résumé par hervé
brusini et bruno carette par est indiqué
que ce sont deux femmes qui ont abattu à
bout portant
le patron de la régie renault à deux pas
du lieu du crime
sa signature ici au métro raspail et
policiers ont retrouvé la revendication
probable de l'attentât contre georges
besse ii traces signés action directe
commando pierrot vernet étonnante
réminiscences de faits vieux de près de
15 ans au vernet jeunes militants
maoïstes tué par un vigile de la régie
en 72 g antoine tramoni lui même est
condamné à cinq ans de prison
à sa sortie il est assassiné par les
nappes ap noyau armée pour l'autonomie
populaire
hier soir les enquêteurs ont
immédiatement démarré leur enquête
recherche des indices les douilles de
trois projectiles calibre 9 mm
et l'audition des premiers témoins à la
brigade criminelle on est désormais
persuadé qu'une jeune femme est bien
l'assassin de georges besse et qu'elle a
agi avec une complice peut être même y
avait-il un homme pour couvrir
l'opération
pourquoi cette certitude de la part des
enquêteurs sur le rôle des deux jeunes
femmes
parce qu'une passante a bel et bien été
braqué par l'une d'entre elles qui lui
aurait dit casse toi t'as rien vu alors
pas de doute pour les enquêteurs le
commando pierre overney était bien
composées d'au moins deux jeunes femmes
françaises des points communs ont été
constatées entre les attentats perpétrés
contre monsieur baisse c'est contre un
diplomate ouest allemand mois d'octobre
dernier à bonn
ces points communs peuvent conforter la
thèse des menées terroristes européenne
et des liens entre action directe et
ceux qui se réclament de la fraction
armée rouge allemande commentaires
dominique tierces
une étoile à cinq branches le sigle de
reconnaissance de trois groupes
clandestins européen
action directe fraction armée rouge
allemande cellules communistes
combattantes belges français et
allemands se sont d'ailleurs unis
officiellement dans le sang c'était en
janvier 85 lors de l'assassinât de
l'ingénieur général rené audran crime
revendiqué par le groupe français
conviction des enquêteurs l'union des
deux groupes s'est prolongé sur le
terrain même de l'attentât
action directe souligner cette fusion en
faisant parvenir à la presse deux textes
l'un en français l'autre en allemand
des deux côtés du rhin les cibles sont
les mêmes munich bonne l'araf s'attaque
depuis deux ans aux personnalités du
monde industriel hauts fonctionnaires
des affaires étrangères aux hommes clés
de la défense nationale en france
action directe revendique la tentative
d'attentât contre guy branagh le vice
président du patronat français
les deux groupes exécutent froidement
unis dans ce qu'ils appellent le front
de guérilla anti impérialiste
car des deux côtés du rhin les méthodes
sont souvent les mêmes
rené audran georges bessière soir le
diplomate allemand
mais le mois dernier ont été abattus par
deux ou trois personnes
coups de feu rapide devant le domicile
des victimes fuite des agresseurs à pied
ou en voiture
dans tous ces cas une certitude pour les
enquêteurs la présence de femmes comme
en allemagne
ces similitudes d'objectifs et d'action
impose en tout cas une étroite
collaboration des services chargés de la
lutte anti terroriste en europe est
contre cette forme d'euro terrorisme en
allemagne fédérale le bureau de
recherche criminelle alors rassemblés
depuis plusieurs années des dizaines de
milliers d'informations cette
coordination policière entend mieux
lutter contre les associations
terroriste franco-allemand à notre
correspondant michel meyer le directeur
du bureau de recherche criminelle
allemand le bk a confirmé avoir prévenu
ses collègues des risques de nouveaux
attentats en france
c'est vrai que sur la base d'une
surenchère entre les terroristes et
allemands et action directe nous avions
depuis fin 84 le sentiment qu'après le
meurtre de fonds de grande mue la bonne
action directe était en quelque sorte de
tenus d'accomplir un crime de même
nature en france on l'a donc dit comme
ça entre policiers à nos collègues
français et notre secrétaire d'état ne
laissèrent l'a répété dans les mêmes
termes
lors d'une rencontre des ministres de
l'intérieur européens à londres
trophée tilly pas de prophétie donc mais
pas d'avertissement concret non plus
personne n'aura en effet pu dire quand
où comment cela allait se passer
une planification des opérations
n'existe sûrement pas entre les groupes
terroristes par contre ces groupes
expriment les mêmes objectifs
idéologiques dans des manifs est commun
en outre ils pratiquent une sorte de jeu
d'alternance et d' escalade dans les
attentats s'inspirant ainsi mutuellement
certains attentats terroristes ont été
revendiqués en commun mais nous sommes
toujours d'avis que ce soit disant fonds
anti impérialiste d'europe occidentale
n'est pas encore une réalité
avec la police française nous ferons
bien entendu tout pour éviter qu'une
telle union se fasse soyons clair le but
des terroristes et des veillées dans
l'opinion européenne une impression de
puissance et d'union question quel rôle
joue la presse dans la stratégie
terroriste
c'est tout un conflit pour nous
l'intérêt majeur des terroristes et
d'occuper les gros titres de la presse
avec leurs crimes sanglants
c'est la seule façon de percevoir
l'effet de leur action il serait donc
souhaitable sans terre ces méfaits de ne
pas leur donner la une
la presse est donc un instrument à
exploiter à utiliser du point de vue des
terroristes la presse est leur seule
tribune ils ne peuvent en effet pas
ouvertement communiquer avec l'opinion
sur une plage de marquer ou ailleurs à
travers des crimes la direction de la
régie renault diffuser cette revue cette
édition spéciale avec c'est le journal
interne à la régie renault avec un
numéro spécial sur la mort de georges
besse l'on lit notamment président de
renault depuis moins de deux ans georges
besse avait engagé le processus de
redressement de l'entreprise l'équipe de
direction est déterminé à poursuivre
dans la voie qu'ils avaient tracé et ce
matin à la sortie des usines de boulogne
billancourt de la régie renault les plus
anciens établissements du groupe
les ouvriers interrogés faisait part de
leur stupéfaction et de leur indignation
le patron georges besse avait sa manière
pour opérer le redressement de la régie
mais c'était un grand patron concluait
bien des ouvriers reportage jean marc
dubois philippe péters 6h ce matin aux
portes des usines renault de
boulogne-billancourt ceylan gauche mais
c'est aussi la surprise beaucoup
d'ouvriers ne sont pas encore au courant
de l'assassinât de georges besse
on aborde une semaine à lens a été
assassiné hier soir je pourrais je sais
comment les premières réactions comme ça
ça nous parle de faire une grande ont
fait ce qu'ils connaissaient la nouvelle
se déclare touchés et condamne
l'assassinât c'est les boutons sais
c'est pas permis
je pense comme ça assez dégueulasse
ils avaient un boulot à faire bon et
assassiner les gens comme sont assez
triste 8h heure dans gauche pour les
cadres même réaction de tristesse on
sentait bien derrière un patron comme ça
une grosse perte
oui tout à fait et l'autorité du côté de
la direction la réaction ne s'est pas
fait attendre
on suivra l'exemple de george besse
profondément renault les premiers succès
de sa politique sont déjà apparents pour
tout le monde l'équipe de direction de
renault est déterminé à poursuivre dans
la voie qu'ils avaient tracé le
président mitterrand comme le premier
ministre jacques chirac alain madelin
comme laurent fabius
edouard balladur comme jean pierre
chevènement et beaucoup d'autres
responsables politiques ont rendu
hommage de façon très ému à georges
besse à ses qualités personnelles et à
ses réalisations de chefs d'entreprise
au cours d'antenne de midi le vice
président du cnpf guy branagh qui
échappa au mois d'avril dernier aux
balles tirées par deux hommes devant son
domicile tentatives d'attentats
revendiqués par action directe
guy branagh parlait des chefs
d'entreprise désormais cible des
terroristes métier d'homme d'entreprises
cde compte des risques et pas forcément
celui là mais lorsque vous êtes à
oublier de fées reçu des calculs de
risques
à titre personnel alors là ça devient
tout à fait anormal monsieur branagh
vous avez peur aujourd'hui
non non ceci mais je pense à tous ceux à
la au grand changement il vient de
s'opérer
il ya quelques années on pouvait être
président de très grandes entreprises en
étant un homme tout à fait normal
maintenant il faut se protéger et
bethenod les responsables économiques
les responsables d'entreprises
je trouve confronté à ce très grave
danger qu'ils ont danger aveugle
inattendu dégueulasse comme le disait un
ouvrier chez renault
ce ne sont plus seulement donc les
hommes politiques que l'on protège mais
aussi ceux qui à titre divers ont des
vies publiques ou des responsabilités
importantes pour la vie économique
française les systèmes de protection
rapprochée reste confidentiel
thierry calmette et jean-marie
lequertier ont cependant qu'ils étaient
sur les moyens de
tg les personnes éventuellement menacer
un déjeuner d'affaires qui aurait pu mal
se terminer sans l'intervention de ses
deux gardes du corps
cette simulation représente un cas
extrême la sécurité rapprochée c'est
d'abord une affaire de renseignements et
de travail quotidien pas du cinéma
ça n'est pas suffisant
un garde du corps une voiture blindée
dix gardes du corps une voiture blindée
des voitures des scores il faut faire un
travail beaucoup plus important de
prévention et de dissuasion en amont
c'est-à-dire procéder à des repérages
procédé dans le cadre de l'environnement
de la ville et le cadre de vie de cette
personnalité de vérifier s'il n'y a pas
des gens qui s'intéressent déjà à son
existence à sa vie à ses habitudes
c'est presque plus grotesque vaches
privé c'est pas du contre-espionnage
disons que pour faire une bonne sécurité
il faut se mettre dans la peau de celui
qui veut commettre une agression
peut-on assurer à 100% la sécurité non
ce soit très ambitieux que de que de
répondre par l'affirmative
la sécurité à 100% n'existe pas bien sûr
on ne règle pas à 100% pour les ponts
déplace le risque vers d'autres
recherches pour cela de se protéger
également la sécurité privée coûte très
cher un seul garder du corps 30 mille
francs par mois location d'une voiture
blindée
2500 francs par jour à l'achat plus d'un
million de francs qu en france il s'en
est vendu 5 6 mois dernier mais ce sont
surtout les pdg de même qu'ils vont
devoir adapter leurs réflexes et leur
habitude au danger qu implique désormais
leurs fonctions georges besse chute
appelé à la tête de la régie renault par
laurent fabius était il y a deux ans et
l'entreprise connaissait de ce très
sérieux déboires les chiffres actuels de
renault le prouve le redressement était
entamée au prix sans doute de sacrifices
sociaux l'après baisse est déjà
commencée alors avec le service
économique et sociale de la rédaction
d'antenne 2 voici les perspectives
renault réalisé
avec moins de personnel m'ont tellement
fragile mais également le structure
c'est un peu ça qu'on s'efforce de faire
100 g cela c'est la méthode baisse dire
la vérité quel que soit l'interlocuteur
ministre ouvrier chez renault en janvier
85 il trouve une situation
catastrophique
l'entreprise perd 12 milliards de francs
elle serait en faillite si ce n'était
pas une régie pendant six mois
georges besse va garder le silence il
fait le tour de chaque usine un examen
secteur par secteur
puis son verdict tombe c'est lui qui
décide les premiers licenciements secs à
la régie impassible dans ce bastion de
la cgt que la régie il fait passer un
message redresser l'entreprise son plan
lancer de nouveaux modèles comme la r21
recentrer les activités sur l'automobile
en abandonnant tous les secteurs non
rentables et reprendre en main un réseau
commercial assoupie lors du dernier
salon il pouvait annoncer que les pertes
de la régie n'atteindrait que 5
milliards et demi cette année une étape
dans le pari qu'il s'était fixé faire
sortir renault du rouge en trois ans
faut savoir que trois ans est une durée
extrêmement limité
traille clerc par exemple a mis cinq ans
fiat également cinq ans après plusieurs
années de maladie avant m c'est donc une
durée faibles et nous espérons arriver
et vous voyez que c'est un effort
formidable
d'après renault pour arriver à ce
résultat il lui restait encore un an
pour réussir son pari aujourd'hui
renault est toujours dans le rouge
la succession de georges besse risque
d'être très difficile
s'il ya un homme qui était capable de
redresser la situation
la régie renault c'était bien lui il
avait commencé à le faire
et pour ce qui me concerne j'avais
toujours attendu avec beaucoup d'espoir
et de certitudes des résultats de son
action
mais je suis convaincu que la régie qui
a vaincu avec georges besse cette
période de mutation a compris le message
et ce message jeu qui est en somme
regardons les choses comme elles sont
mettant tout à plat
nous sommes dans une véritable guerre
mondiale dans le domaine de l'automobile
d'autres entreprises ont été redressés
aux états unis ou ailleurs alors qu'elle
était plus bas que terre
pourquoi pas nous 1 ce message est passé
tout ne tient pas dans la politique d'un
homme
nous avons combattu sa stratégie mais
qui était soutenu par des gouvernements
la direction a annoncé qu'elle
continuerait la stratégie actuelle de la
ddt décidée et par conséquent il n'ya
pas d'illusion à se faire il faut donc
que les travailleurs continuent à se
mobiliser et à dire que cette politique
est mauvaise parce qu'elle met en cause
notre potentiel industriel et humain
la succession sera délicate à la tête de
la régie renault
ici à l'immeuble de la direction
générale on ne veut pas en parler pour
l'instant l'heure est encore au
recueillement à l'émotion
d'ailleurs les drapeaux sont en berne
pour la première fois ce qu'on sait pour
l'instant c'est qu'un directeur général
adjoint a été choisi pour assurer
l'intérim de georges besse
il s'appelle aimé jardon il a réuni cet
après midi une partie des
administrateurs pour leur dire on
continue sur la même voie
y at il un homme qui émerge parmi les
cadres dirigeants de la régie
on pourrait citer plusieurs noms comme
celui du directeur commercial josé de
dornach d'air mais le pdg d'une origine
est pas forcément un homme du sérail
c'est le gouvernement qui le choisit en
conseil des ministres et pour le
gouvernement ce choix est difficile car
l'homme doit avoir la capacité de
poursuivre une oeuvre entamé les
résultats du commerce extérieur de la
france pour le mois d'octobre sont
pratiquement équilibré pratiquement
carhaisien déficit de 100 millions de
francs c'est mieux ou moins mauvais que
le déficit précédent au mois de
septembre qui était de 2,9 milliards de
francs le ministre des affaires sociales
philippe seguin veut rationaliser les
dépenses d'assurance-maladie 9 milliards
d'économies l'année prochaine ce qui est
envisagé par monsieur seguin
parmi les mesures et il ya la
suppression de la franchise postale
l'augmentation du forfait hospitalier
journalier et l'obligation pour les
pharmaciens doter les vignettes des
médicaments vendus sans ordonnance afin
d'empêcher qu'ils soient remboursés
explications véronique auger profitez-en
jusqu'au 1er janvier prochain le
courrier envoyé à la sécurité sociale
bénéficie encore de la franchise postale
après le 1er janvier il faudra mettre un
timbre cela permettra à la sécu
d'économiser les 900 millions de francs
qu'elle verse tous les ans aux ptt
deuxième mesure le forfait hospitalier
augmente de 2 francs par jour dès le 1er
janvier les hôpitaux vous factureront 25
francs pour vos frais d'hôtellerie
troisième mesure les pharmaciens vos
hôtes et les vignettes des médicaments
vendus sans ordonnance afin d'éviter les
fraudes
la sécurité sociale ne remboursera plus
les vitamines sauf la b12 et la vitamine
t
enfin et surtout la liste des 25
maladies remboursés à 100% va être
remise à jour certaines seront
supprimées
le sida sera rajoutée par ailleurs le
système de la 26ème maladie est
abandonné il permettait un remboursement
à 100% à tous les malades qui déboursait
plus de 80 francs par mois pour se
soigner pendant plus d'un semestre
ces mesures sont critiqués par la
confédération syndicale des familles qui
estime que l'on va pénaliser les
familles qui ont moins de revenus le
ministre de l'économie et douars
balladur rendait public aujourd'hui une
série de mesures pour réaménager les
prêts aux particuliers aux entreprises
et pour assouplir le contrôle des
changes les chances sont libérés à 90%
affirme monsieur balladur et pour
préciser les nouvelles modalités du
contrôle du crédit commenté philippe
sassier l'encadrement du crédit est
supprimé à partir du 1er janvier
prochain
on ne fixera plus comme dans le passé
une quantité annuelle de crédit que les
banques distribuent et sans se faire
trop de concurrence désormais le
contrôle du crédit se fera à travers les
taux d'intérêt ceux-ci varieront à la
hausse ou à la baisse selon que le
niveau de la demande sera trop fort ou
pas assez cela ne signifie pas pour nous
emprunteurs un crédit forcément plus
cher mais l'étau varieront beaucoup plus
rapidement et il devrait y avoir
davantage de concurrence entre les
banques
enfin une nouvelle étape est franchie
dans la suppression du contrôle des
changes les français pourront se servir
librement de leur carte de crédit ou
bien acheter une résidence secondaire ou
des actions de bourses à l'étranger
edouard balladur a annoncé la fin de
certains contrôles sur des opérations de
commerce extérieur
mais pour empêcher une spéculation
éventuelles contre le franc il n'a pas
rendu leur entière liberté auprès que
l'on peut consentir en dehors de france
et la troisième fois en cinquante ans
que nous levons le contrôle des chances
cela devrait permettre à paris l'affirmé
son rôle de places financières en
récupérant des activités qui se font
actuellement obligatoirement à londres
ou à francfort
le conseil constitutionnel après examen
de la loi sur le découpage électoral a
décidé que celle ci n'était pas
contraire à la constitution le conseil
constitutionnel a précisé qu'ils ne
trancher que sur la forme
s'estimant incompétent sur le fond du
recours des députés socialistes
l'écart entre la population d'une
circonscription et la population moyenne
d'un même département n'est pas
disproportionné de manière excessive
c'est ce qui est écrit dans la décision
du conseil constitutionnel alors à
gauche on regrette cette décision
le communiste lajoinie estime que l'on
donne quitus à monsieur pasqua et le
socialiste jean-pierre michel considère
que les pressions de la majorité ont
porté dans
et puis à droite côté gouvernemental
notamment on se réjouit jean eu de
scènes que vous savez où d'un langage
journalistique nous disons souvent comme
pour nous une excuse et qu'on ne parle
pas des trains qui arrivent à l'heure et
pourtant cet après-midi le train du
palais royal est arrivée à l'heure mais
pas sur la voie où l'attendait rappelez
vous la colère des élus de droite
lorsque pierre joxe au nom du ps
remettent en cause une des institutions
voulues en 58 par le général de gaulle
souvenez-vous du tollé quand la haute
institution s'est vu proposé comme
président le garde des sceaux qui plus
est ami personnel de françois mitterrand
robert badinter
toutes ces critiques comme par
enchantement vol ce soir en éclats à
gauche qu'on se résigne difficilement à
droite on jubile hier mitterrand
émettait des réserves et refusait de
signer les ordonnances
aujourd'hui le conseil constitutionnel
donne son aval à la loi qui est le
calque même des ordonnances ce n'est pas
pour autant un désaveu du chef de l'état
il s'est posé des questions il a ce soir
les réponses à ces questions
oui la procédure de découpage n'a pas
été irrégulière oui les écarts
démographiques de circonscription à
circonscriptions ne sont pas excessifs
enfin le conseil constitutionnel n'est
pas une cour suprême à l'américaine il
reconnaît lui même qu'il a moins de
pouvoir que le parlement de l'autre côté
pour le gouvernement renie et un morceau
de la loi mégoter sur une
circonscription chipoter sur un canton
c'était remettre en cause tout l'édifice
c'était obligatoirement repartir de zéro
mais le conseil constitutionnel a
tranché qu'on conteste ici ou là son
mode de nomination qu'on suggère sont
d'ailleurs pouvoir le prouver que ses
attendus sont motivées par des
considérations autres que
constitutionnelles
en clair des motivations politiques il
est là et bien là et ce soir grâce à lui
on sait que l'époque 85-86 l'époque de
la proportionnelle n'aura été qu'une
parenthèse dans l'histoire de la vème
république
sauf sauf à recommencer
aux etats unis une nouvelle rumeur sur
une possible démission de monsieur
schulz la décision du président reagan
de fournir des armes à l'iran décision
contestée par monsieur chaude serait à
l'origine de ces rumeurs même si
président reagan déclaré hier qu'il
n'avait pas l'intention de livrer de
nouvelles armes interrogé par la chaîne
de télévision et demi
si les anciens président gerald ford à
gauche et jimmy carter à droite se sont
prononcés contre de telles transactions
pour monsieur forts des leçons très
mauvaise pour tous les contacts avec
l'arabie saoudite et le koweït on a
l'impression que les états unis ont payé
une véritable rançon pour les otages et
monsieur carter ici a demandé que toute
la lumière soit faite sur ces ventes
d'armes à jacques à bouchehr pour
antenne 2 à washington l'un des
conseillers du président reagan monsieur
donald reagan vient d'affirmer que
l'iran allait bien changé et que
l'embargo était maintenu vous affirmez
que les envois d'armes à l'iran sont
destinés à encourager les éléments
modérés de terrain alors pourquoi dans
ces conditions vous n'envoyez pas des
armes aux modérés en syrie ou encore en
libye
nous en avons débattu ici aux etats unis
nous avons fait un geste de bonne
volonté en retour il était entendu que
l'iran devait suspendre tout acte de
terrorisme contre notre pays ou contre
des citoyens américains
et depuis il n'y a plus d'incident
imputable à téhéran vous considérez donc
l'iran ne commande dit plus d'actes de
terrorisme absolument et contrairement à
la syrie c'est pourquoi d'ailleurs nous
avons décidé d'appliquer des sanctions
contre ce pays contre la syrie vous avez
toujours demandé aux européens en
particulier à la france de ne pas vendre
d'armes à l'inca l'iran c'est exact
est-ce que vous pouvez maintenir une
telle position vis-à-vis de vos alliés
oui parce que nous avons fait une
exception mineurs en livrant un liant
des armes strictement défensive et en
quantité très limitée
ce qui ne changera pas le cours de la
guerre vous parlez d'exemption mineurs -
autres européens avons tendance à
considérer que vous avez fait une
exception majeure c'est grave car vous
disiez certaines choses sur le
terrorisme iranien et vous faisiez
exactement le contraire
pour nous aussi c'est grave mais encore
une fois nous n'avons vendu que très peu
d'armes
la guerre se poursuit et nous faisons
tout pour l'arrêter
libre à vous de considérer que nous
avons commis une violation de notre
propre politique le président la corée
du nord kim il sung
annoncé comme mort par le ministère
sud-coréen de la défense est réapparu il
est bien vivant si on en croit ces
images venues de la télévision chinoise
une cérémonie officielle avec
commentaires enthousiastes enthousiaste
pour l'accueil du secrétaire général du
parti communiste mongol kim il sung et
donc bien vivant et à paris le
contrôleur général monsieur jacques
delebois chef du service de la
coopération technique internationale de
la police
entendu par les juges d'instruction
chargés de la faire du carrefour du
développement a été remis en liberté
après plusieurs heures de garde à vue
le même juge d'instruction a accédé à la
demande de m bernard prévôt avocats de
maggie bastian lahmidi chalier maggie
bastian a été remise en liberté et placé
sous contrôle judiciaire
l'écrivain roger ikor est décédé la nuit
dernière à l'âge de 74 ans il avait reçu
le prix goncourt en 1955 pour les eaux
mêlées
il fut surtout celui qui dénonça les
sectes il commença sa lutte contre les
manipulations mentales après le suicide
de l'un de ses fils roger ikor appelait
à la dissolution des sectes aux obsèques
de thierry le luron en l'église de la
madeleine à paris le père jean michel di
falco a conclu ainsi son homélie
j'oserais demander une chose avec humour
et amour d'aider les glandus que nous
sommes tus reste avec nous même si on ne
te voit pas ce nous étaient inconnus et
célèbres ce matin inconnu célèbre des
hommes politiques des artistes ce que le
luron imitait sont venus le saluer
commentaires emmanuel vanier des fleurs
beaucoup de fleurs
c'était ce que thierry lui même avait
demandé à tous ses amis ils sont venus
très nombreux ce matin à l'église de la
madeleine pour se recueillir
elle lui rendre un dernier hommage
solennel a mis du spectacle et du
show-business et personnalités
politiques
tous ont eu à pâtir des imitations
parfois féroce de thierry mais ce matin
les visages étaient graves
recueillie et puis un peu plus loin des
milliers d'anonymes certains sont
arrivés en pleine nuit ils ont attendu
debout pendant des heures
la cérémonie religieuse n'a duré qu'une
heure dans son homélie
l'un des prêtres qui concédait brel à
metz a dit à thierry ge de sites
tu restes avec nous même si on ne te
voit pas et là où au paradis tu vas à
portée le rayon de ta jeunesse et faire
rire le bon dieu et tout c'est ça
l'explosion accidentelle cet après midi
dans les sous sol d'un immeuble du
ministère des affaires étrangères dans
le 7e arrondissement à paris
huit sapeurs-pompiers ont été gravement
blessées et trois plus légèrement le
sinistre ayant fait exploser des
bouteilles d'acétylène les pompiers
gravement brûlées ont été transportés
par hélicoptère notamment vers des
hôpitaux spécialisés
et pour ajouter à la liste des mauvaises
nouvelles
'l'annonce par la préfecture maritime de
brest annonce selon laquelle les
recherches entreprises dans l'atlantique
pour retrouver le navigateur loïc
caradec ont été abandonnées sport
football demain à 20h sur antenne 2 en
direct championnat d'europe des nations
france république démocratique allemande
à la musique pour cette rencontre et
michel a choisi une équipe très
renforcée en défens vous allez voir la
composition de cette équipe de france
avec le nantais yvon le roux dans
l'entrejeu comme on dit stopyra et papin
et tantale attaque
c'est une rencontre très importante pour
l'avenir de l'équipe de france voici le
commentaire de dominique tu joues mal
partie l'équipe de france accroché en
islande battu au parc 2 0 par lurcy il
ya juste un mois
elle occupe la dernière place de son
groupe ex-aequo avec la norvège demain à
l'epci face à la rda
elle joue pratiquement à quitte ou
double si on veut garder un espoir de
qualification mais aussi de votre pc ces
points perdus et la meilleure façon de
le faire c'est d'essayer de les
grappiller à l'extérieur donc que ça
commence fort chômage de de la rda et
c'est vrai que si on ne prenait pas de
poids rd1
on pourrait on peut penser qu en serait
presque éliminé des fils du moment et
comme l'équipe de france n'a jamais bien
réussi à l'extérieur et surtout en
république démocratique allemande
il y a juste un an elle y fut battu 2 0
henri michel a décidé avant tout de
construire sur du solide
le solide c'est un pur produit breton de
26 ans yvon leroux stoppent leur à
nantes titulariser ici en milieu de
terrain défensif pratiquement à double
stoppeur ya quelques années de ça on me
reproche toujours ma gentillesse le
terrain bon ça ça m'a beaucoup marqué
bon et quand je suis sur le terrain
maintenant je ne loue pas respecté ses
fesses ou marcher dessus par les
attaquants il ya quelques années de ça
maintenant je me dis bon feu respecté
surtout le joueur anthony vaut se
respecte est tellement respecté qu'il
est souvent victime de sa générosité des
cartons rouges entre autres qui lui ont
coûté le mondial 86
pourtant ils vont n'est jamais méchant
seulement son physique impressionne et
on oublie il s'est aussi attaqué qu'il
est doté d'une excellente frappe de
balle et que son jeu de tête pourrait
éventuellement nous servir
on sera donc demain à 20h sur antenne 2
journal sera 19h30 la météo je maintiens
elia demain où tout beau sur le sud ou
tout mauvais sur le nord nous allons
voir sur notre carte du temps prévu pour
demain
voici sur le nord les pluies les nuages
seront surtout abondant le matin sur la
bretagne la normandie et le nord
ils seront abondants ligne a et les
pluies sur la vendée le bassin parisien
et les ardennes quelques éclaircies sur
l'alsace partout ailleurs un grand beau
temps mais après seulement la
dissipation des brouillards matinaux
les températures elles sont vous allez
voir 13 environ c'est la moyenne avec
des extrêmes de 10 à lille est de 18
ajaccio demain mercredi 19 novembre 3
minutes de soleil en moins
le jour se lèvera 8h07 se couchera 17h05
ce sera la sainte en guise merci c'est à
23h45 vous retrouverez avec l'autre pour
le dernier journal de la rédaction
d'antenne 2 demain le journal et à 19h30
10h30
car le match france-eire dr est à 20
heures bonsoir merci